tengo por acá a esta función que que
está expresada como un polinomio de
cuarto grado y lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es pensar acerca de los
intervalos sobre los cuales g es cóncava
hacia arriba o cóncava hacia abajo ahora
recordemos un poco a qué me refiero con
eso cuando tenemos una concavidad hacia
arriba es más déjame escribirlo cuando
tenemos una concavidad hacia arriba
bueno en ese intervalo la pendiente va a
estar incrementando y tiende a verse
como como una abierta lo puedes ver aquí
y observamos que la pendiente justo aquí
es negativa y luego conforme x aumenta
se vuelve menos negativa se aproxima a 0
se vuelve 0 pasa el 0 y se vuelve
ligeramente positiva más positiva y aún
más positiva así que pueden ver que la
pendiente en este caso está creciendo
constantemente
y piensas en términos de derivadas
quiere decir que la primera derivada
está creciendo sobre ese intervalo y
para que su primera derivada esté
creciendo sobre ese intervalo eso quiere
decir que la segunda derivada tiene que
ser mayor que cero es decir en una
concavidad hacia arriba la primera
derivada crece lo que significa que la
segunda derivada tiene que ser mayor que
cero y ahora qué pasa con una concavidad
hacia abajo bueno pasa justo lo
contrario así que vamos a escribirlo
tenemos ahora el caso de una concavidad
hacia abajo y entonces cómo se vería
bueno pues se va a ver más o menos así y
en este caso qué pasa
podemos decir que g prima de x
ha de crecer ha de crecer lo que
significa que la segunda derivada de
esta función que va a ser menor que cero
y entonces esto se vería más o menos así
tú tienes esta función
tienes una pendiente que es positiva se
va volviendo cada vez menos positiva
menos positiva se vuelve 0 y después
empieza a convertirse en negativa más
negativa y más negativa como puedes ver
nuestra pendiente de crece
constantemente mientras x que es así que
para pensar en los intervalos en donde
está es cóncava hacia arriba o hacia
abajo lo que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar la segunda derivada de g y
luego vamos a pensar acerca de los
puntos donde la segunda derivada puede
ir de ser positiva a negativa o de
negativa a positiva y esos serán los
lugares en donde bueno o va a ser
indefinida o donde la segunda derivada
sea igual a 0 y después vamos a ver qué
pasa en los intervalos en medio de esos
puntos para así saber sobre qué
intervalos la función será
hacia abajo o cóncava se arrima así que
manos a la obra
vamos a hacerlo y para eso lo primero
que voy a hacer es sacar la primera
derivada de esta función de x y se
observa que es simplemente aplicar la
regla de las potencias varias veces así
que aquí tengo x elevado a la cuarta y
si aplicamos las realidades potencias
para la derivada me va a quedar que esto
es menos 4 x a la 4 - 1 lo cual es 3 y
después aquí tengo 6 x cuadrada
aplicando la regla de las potencias este
2 va a multiplicar este 6 y me quedaría
2x elevado la potencia 2 - 1 lo cual es
1 entonces lo voy a dejar decir 2x y
después tengo aquí menos 2 o bueno menos
2 x a la 0 lo cual es simplemente menos
2 y la derivada de menos 3 la derivada
de una constante 0 así que no hay que
ponerla y ahora vamos a sacar también la
segunda derivada
y prima de x
y para sacar la segunda derivada observa
que también vamos a aplicar la ley de
las potencias menos 4x cúbica si lo
derivó me va a quedar menos 12 x
cuadrada menos 12 x cuadrada y después
tengo la derivada de 12 x lo cual es
simplemente 12 y la derivada de menos 2
se va es 0 ok ahora observa esta función
donde podría estar indefinida bueno la
segunda derivada es sólo una expresión
cuadrática la cual está definida para
cualquier x así que no va a ser
indefinida en ningún lado ahora entonces
los puntos interesantes donde podríamos
pasar por una segunda derivada negativa
a una positiva o de una positiva a una
negativa son donde esto de aquí sea
igual a cero así que vamos a encontrar
eso vamos a encontrar donde menos 2
x cuadrada más 12 esto sea igual a 0 y
para eso bueno qué te parece si restamos
12 de ambos lados y me quedarían menos
12 x cuadrada esto es igual a menos 12 y
ahora qué te parece divido todo entre
menos 12 y me va a quedar que x cuadrada
es igual a 1 o de otra manera
x es igual a más menos la raíz cuadrada
de 1 lo cual es 1 entonces la segunda
derivada de más menos 1 es igual a cero
así que en cualquier lado entre más uno
o menos uno podríamos tener una
concavidad hacia arriba o una concavidad
hacia abajo y vamos a pensar en eso y
para ello voy a hacer por acá una recta
numérica ok
déjame poner que esta es una recta
numérica por aquí tengo no se deja
meterme por acá el valor de cero
y bueno si este es el valor de 0 por acá
me voy a tomar el valor de 1
y por acá voy a tener el valor de 2 muy
por acá voy a tener el valor de menos 1
y por acá voy a tener el valor de menos
2 de lujo y lo que nosotros sabemos es
que en x igual a menos 1 y en x
igual a 1 mi segunda derivada vale 0 así
que vamos a pensar qué pasaría en los
tres intervalos que nos quedan a
continuación vamos a ver si en este
primer intervalo nuestra segunda
derivada es positiva o negativa y así
seremos capaces de decir si es cóncava
se arriba o cóncava hacia abajo en ese
intervalo así que primero fijémonos en
este intervalo que tengo aquí es decir
me estoy explicando en el intervalo que
va de menos infinito hasta menos 1 si
probamos un valor para saber si la
segunda derivada es positiva o negativa
entonces un valor fácil de probar sería
en menos 2 vamos a ver qué pasa con la
segunda derivada en el valor de menos 2
bueno pues que me quedaría si evaluamos
menos 2 en esta segunda derivada
voy a tener menos 12 x bueno aquí
tendría 4 menos 12 por 4 lo cual es
menos 48 más 12 bueno eso es menos 36 y
lo importante aquí no es el valor que
obtengo sino que en todo este intervalo
la segunda derivada es negativa ya que
no estamos pasando el 0 ni es
discontinua esta función en ninguno de
estos puntos y es por eso que escogimos
justo este intervalo entonces durante
todo este intervalo la segunda derivada
es negativa lo que quiere decir que
tenemos una concavidad hacia abajo
déjame escribirlo muy bien ahora
fijémonos qué es lo que pasa en el
siguiente intervalo y ahora me voy a
fijar en este intervalo que tengo aquí
el que va de menos 1 hasta 1
en todo este intervalo que tengo aquí
déjenme escribirlo va de menos 1 hasta 1
y de igual manera vamos a probar un
valor para evaluar la segunda derivada y
el valor más sencillo que se me ocurre
es cero así que voy a ver cuánto vale la
segunda derivada en el valor de cero
bueno pues vamos a sustituir cero en
esta función y eso es muy sencillo esto
se elimina y me queda simplemente 12 y
recuerda lo importante no es el valor
que obtengamos sino el signo de la
segunda derivada en este caso mi segunda
derivada va a ser mayor que cero pero
para todo este intervalo recuerda y eso
quiere decir que tenemos una concavidad
hacia arriba déjame escribirlo muy bien
y finalmente vamos a ver el intervalo
donde tenemos los valores más grandes
que uno me voy a fijar en todo este
intervalo que tengo aquí todo este
intervalo que tengo aquí que se observa
es el intervalo que va de uno hasta
infinito
bueno vamos a probar de igual manera con
un valor para ver qué es lo que pasa con
la segunda derivada y el valor más fácil
que se me ocurre es tomarme dos así que
cuánto vale la segunda derivada en dos
bueno pues si observas aquí me va a
quedar lo mismo que lo que tenía en
menos dos porque menos dos al cuadrado
lo mismo que dos al cuadrado esos cuatro
entonces me quedarían menos 48 más 12 lo
cual es 36 negativos menos 36 ok lo que
me dice que en todo este intervalo la
segunda derivada ok va a ser menor que
cero y bueno de nuevo no está diciendo
que tenemos una concavidad hacia abajo
bien ahora qué te parece si vamos a ver
la gráfica de esta función que tengo
aquí y vemos si realmente a lo que
llegamos es congruente con lo que se ve
en la gráfica así que para eso déjenme
mover un poco la pantalla para que veas
por aquí lo que está pasando con la
gráfica que voy a traer a continuación
quiero que te des cuenta que hasta aquí
hemos sido capaz de llegar con estas
ideas de concavidad sin graficar pero
ahora déjenme traer por acá la gráfica
la tengo justo por aquí y vamos a
echarle un vistazo a esta gráfica y si
te das cuenta logramos hacer que los
intervalos coincidieran aquí tengo al
menos uno aquí tengo al menos uno que
por cierto sabemos que es un punto en
donde la segunda derivada es igual a
cero y también en x igual a 1 así que si
observas aquí tenemos x igual a 1 y ahí
es un punto donde también mi segunda
derivada es igual a 0 y ahora lo que
estoy diciendo es que en este intervalo
de aquí de menos infinito a 1
déjame ponerlo con su respectivo color
en todo este intervalo que tengo aquí
tengo una concavidad hacia abajo en todo
este intervalo que tengo aquí la
pendiente de la recta tangente está
constantemente decreciendo eso quiere
decir que mi segunda derivada es menor
que cero y se observa se ve correcto ya
que la pendiente está decreciendo hasta
llegar a este valor de 1 donde la
segunda derivada es igual a 0 y después
en el siguiente intervalo la pendiente
empieza a crecer crece crece crece crece
sigue creciendo hasta llegar al valor de
0 y después empecé a volver positiva
positiva positiva hasta llegar a este
punto que tengo aquí en donde x es igual
a 1 y a partir de ese punto la pendiente
ahora empieza a decrecer es positiva se
pasa a ser 0 y después se convierte en
negativa
negativa negativa hasta infinito así que
ya está tenemos aquí una concavidad
hacia abajo aquí una concavidad hacia
arriba y aquí una concavidad hacia abajo
así que pudimos encontrar la concavidad
con solo sacar las derivadas y haciendo
un poco de álgebra ahora ya podemos
verlo claramente en esta gráfica